my name is Lu D'Andrea I work at Wolfram
research I was one of the people working
on manipulate when we built it back in
2007 for version six I'm gonna give a
brief overview of it and then I'm gonna
look at some of the things that people
have had trouble doing with it
by virtue of asking questions on whole
community Stack Exchange and Stack
Overflow sort of getting to the point
where we actually are seeing the the
real problems that real people are
having maybe some of you will have some
insights after seeing the things that
we're talking about today so to the
refresher first manipulate has a syntax
very much like table by the way one
other piece of prep stop me at any point
during this talk to ask a relevant
question so syntax of manipulate much
like table you have as the first
argument an expression that has some
variables in it and then the remaining
arguments are domain specifications for
those variables you can have an a
continuous domain an analog domain of
various kinds and unlike table rather
than just showing you the full list of
all possible combinations it shows you
an interface in which you can choose
which part of the parameter space you're
interested in so you can you can
navigate your way through this
multi-dimensional parameter space I
can't leave it at that color there we go
okay and it does this by sea by using
controls that match your system
appearance of control so on a Mac these
sliders look like Mac sliders and the
radio buttons look like Mac radio
buttons if I were up here with the
Windows machine they would look natural
to a Windows user etc also notice that
other than this last control I didn't
say anything about an interface there's
nothing interfacing about this input you
don't need to know about interfaces in
order to use manipulate you know you
need to know a little bit about them to
customize manipulate but just to use it
out of the box you don't need to it does
some very nice automatic things for you
like localizing names which we'll talk
about
a little bit it'll let you specify
different aspects of a control that
gives you labeling or initial value
concerns etc bottom line here is that
manipulate doesn't require you to know
anything about interfaces in order to
build interfaces at a very high level so
this is the manipulate syntax and what
kinds of control specifications variable
specifications do we support in
manipulate well there are a small
handful that it would probably be who've
people to to learn we can specify like
table min Max or min Max step of course
we can also specify a multi dimensional
control like a slider 2d or a locator so
those are specified with a pair of men's
or a pair of Max's and the right-hand
column here in bold is the control type
that's used automatically by manipulate
when it encounters a control
specification that looks like the thing
in the left-hand column the remaining
items in the right-hand column are
control types that you can use if you
want to override manipulates built-in
choice
so a manipulator this manipulator
control I should show you what that is
it looks like a slider with some
additional controls hidden with an
opener you open it up you get a small
constellation including an input field
and some animation controls this
collection of slider plus animator plus
input field plus opener is known as
manipulator and that's the default
control type for certain parameter
specifications but we have you know we
have then you can specify as I said
earlier these analog controls where
you're selecting one out of many many
plate goes back and forth between using
pop-up menu or setter bar for the
default in this case depending on how
long the list is for short lists it
shows you all of them in a setter bar
and for more than seven or eight it will
show you them as a menu etc
and as I've already mentioned there are
sin taxes that can be used to alter
individual lines of your manipulate so
here we have a manipulate by default you
get the variable name as the label and
the initial value is chosen by
Mathematica and the case for these
continuous controls the choice is the
left endpoint but you can change the
initial value using a syntax like this
where you specify not the variable X but
a list X with initial value if you
specify a third element you can specify
initial label initial value and a label
so notice that the location of the
slider thumb is now in the middle and
the label has changed you can also
specify as we've said can override
manipulates built-in control choice by
using the control type option and once
you have a control type you can specify
other options for that control within
this parameter spec so you have you say
I want this to be an animator and I know
about animator it's a built-in thing I
know it has some options and these are
the options I want to set for this
particular animator in this case if we
didn't have any options here the
animator would display and immediately
start to run if we evaluate this after
adding an option animation running
keyboard sometimes doesn't like me so
here we have an animator that's that is
initially paused alright so any options
that you can specify for animator you
can specify within this control spec any
options for interval slider
you could put here etc so okay one other
thing I want to touch on at some length
is variable scoping so it was important
for us when building manipulate that one
didn't have to think too hard about what
variable names had values in your
session already so in this case we
didn't want an input like this
manipulate of some
Fibonacci polynomials too to be affected
if n happen to have a value in in our
session we also didn't want multiple
manipulates based on the same variable
name to interfere with one another so
and that's what we built
so Fibonacci polynomials to degree n
notice that the plot below is not moving
and even though it also is manipulating
the variable n if I move the plot around
notice that the polynomials aren't
changing so these ends are separate from
one another and they're separate from
the global value of n I'm going to talk
a bit about this what good is this and
why do we do this and how hard was it
well the variable scoping for manipulate
actually had to happen in two different
places the first was in the initial
evaluation of the manipulate in the
kernel which is not something that
people tend to think deeply about and
there'll be a couple times today when we
need to mention it but the other time is
when using copy and paste completely
without a kernel so here we have a
manipulated output I'm going to just
copied it and I'm going to paste it I
have another copy of this manipulate
should one of these sliders affect the
other well we didn't think so we thought
we would want these to be completely
separate so merely the act of copy and
paste creates a new scoping construct
that means that the scoping construct
had to be something that's built into
the box structure in the front end
that's why we developed a dynamic module
box as a scoping construct that exists
for rectangles in the front end so we
drag these around and these are in fact
separate so so have you built dynamic
module box and dynamic module box also
has some nice features in that it
automatically enables us to save values
to files so the box gives us space the
syntax for dynamic module box is a lot
like module and it gives a space in the
file to put the local module variables
that are being remembered by this
dynamic module box okay
so we get to our first frequently asked
questions
the V is very so this is I was actually
surprised when I went through community
and other places and started looking at
problems that people were having I was
surprised that this was the number one
problem that people were having but it
was at least in the forum's that I know
about so people often have a utility
function does something interesting this
one doesn't do anything particularly
interesting it just evaluates sign of a
X the X is a local variable in F and the
a is a local variable in the subsequent
manipulate but evaluating this doesn't
show my plot it doesn't show sign of a X
and this doesn't help so what's going on
here well manipulate uses dynamic module
boxes I've already mentioned dynamic
module uses the same kind of scoping as
is used by module in the kernel and
scoping is the key to understanding this
particular issue so module uses lexical
scoping I won't go I won't take a deep
dive into modules form of scoping
suffice it to say that that a lexically
scoped symbol in such a construct can
only be referenced from within that
construct so if you had a module in fact
if we looked at the same example in a
module we have module with a local
variable a and the a in this case only
ever exists during the evaluation of
this module and only exists lexically
for references to a that are inside this
module there is no other reference to a
inside this module there's a reference
to a and the definition of F that sort
of the gets the ambient a from the ether
somewhere but it's not passed through
and so because of the way scoping works
this is just a non-starter and here's an
even simpler example to drive the point
home here we have just trying to get the
value of F of 1 if F of 1 let's see X is
1 so that's one a if a is 1 then there
should be a sine of 1 times 1 but it's
not at sine of a because the a and the
function definition is not the same as
the
in the module and likewise it's not the
same as the a and the manipulate so how
do you get your utility functions to
know about local variables in some other
scope
well you pass them through as arguments
so here is here's the way that one could
rewrite this code to make it work rather
than f of X we pass the variable a
through as a value out so we have we
have now built a tunnel out of the
scoping construct and into this utility
perhaps this is just not well understood
for module but I was surprised to find
this being one of the one of the
sticking points for people using
manipulate but if we do this in
manipulate and we pass through we pass
the local variables through to the to
the outside world then the outside world
you know comes to life and our
manipulate now works and I this example
by the way was not something I
constructed this is I shouldn't do that
one the original example that I've
talked about this is this is literally
an example that somebody posted on I
forget if it was Stack Exchange or
community
here's another one that someone
literally posted these are not academic
examples that I'm inventing these are
real problems that real people had again
we have this time a pair of functions
this time it's why that takes the value
of X and somehow expects to grab the
value of X not from somewhere but it's
not passing it through and so it's not
going to work I think why is the tangent
line or wants to be the tangent line to
F here but there's no tangent being
shown how do we fix this again you pass
the value through as a local variable
and then there's the tangent line okay
question
the question is would a replace global a
goes to a work the answer is no because
that's not the direction you want you
want the global definition to refer to
your local manipulate construct your
local your scoped variable and we can
look more at that after if you like but
I think the answer is no okay so
throughout this talk I'm gonna have some
bonus slides I'm not opening any of
these bonus slide content this notebook
already exists on the passable site the
bonus slides are for you when you get
this notebook back in your own office
hotel room subway whatever take a look
at the bonus slides and you'll get
you'll get maybe another 30 minutes
worth of stuff out of this notebook so
you're welcome
so what else what other common problems
are there another common well this is a
collection of problems with a common
solution collection of problems is I
don't know what's going wrong with my
manipulate it's turning pink things are
going bad I don't know what to do and
it's giving error messages but this is
manipulate and I don't know anything
about interfaces so help so one of the
very useful things and I have an
anecdote about this that I'll tell in a
moment one very useful thing is in every
manipulate so here's a maple 8 that's
going to break and every manipulate with
default options there is a menu up in
the corner with some controls now some
of these controls are rather flashy
there's one I think that doesn't really
get the attention it deserves and that's
paste snapshot which takes out of the
manipulate the body and all of the local
values of all of the local variables and
produces a new input not a manipulated
input it is a dynamic module input but
it produces a new input that gives you
the ability to dig into this particular
frame of the manipulate and what might
be going on so I used this technique
today today to track down a bug
in somebody else's code so here we have
we see we have exactly the same error
messages in fact even with module
instead of dynamic module still have
error messages but at this point users
might think oh well I'm not in
manipulated anymore I can actually read
this message and make some sense of it
so they'll pause hopefully read the
message say endpoints for y must have
distinct machine pursue oh so we have Y
going from 1 to K and K is 1 ah
so if K we're 1.1 is that is that kind
of fit oh but now X has the same problem
because X goes from 0 to n and n is 0 so
we can't have X going from 0 to 0 or
parametric plot will complain
there we go so this gives a way to drill
down into the problem and and make some
headway and this was supposed to be
marked as bonus so you're welcome so
very common to see pinking as a result
of kernel messages generated during a
dynamic update you see dynamic of 1 over
0 creates a little pink box but it
doesn't show you the message until you
do something take a look at this slide
later to find out what to do about that
ok another category of problems my
manipulate is slow why does the cell
bracket keep lighting up how can I avoid
doing I have I have a manipulate that
shows something that uses a lot of work
and something that needs very little
work when I update this I don't want
this to change how do I do that
and this category of problems each of
each of the solutions I'm about to
describe
can affect any one of that in the
category so this is sort of a mix and
match these are all good techniques to
know so what can I say about the cell
bracket staying lit well we've all
experienced a dynamic that just keeps
running and running and running maybe we
have has anybody in this room
experienced that ok a few so this is
because dynamic tries really hard to
make
or that it always shows you the current
value of an expression and it does that
by remembering all of the symbols that
are involved in that expression and
keeping track of each of them and if any
of those changes it updates the dynamic
it it sends a message that says the
dynamic needs to be updated and this is
very very good and sometimes it's very
useful so for instance here is a
manipulate that I wrote some time ago
that uses a pen to to continue to
continually add to a list iteratively
notice there's no animator in this
manipulate call this is this is driving
itself by virtue of having a variable
whose value is changing inside of
dynamic so this dynamic evaluates it
notices that it depends on the value of
lists the value of lists changes during
this dynamic update and then the system
says hey this dynamic depends on lists
lists changed you need to update and so
this runs and runs and runs and we can
say well don't change lists this time
around because I have this paused when
you're paused then you're not doing any
work list is not changing the updates
not changing okay so sometimes I guess
I'm driving home the point that this
dynamic infinite evaluation and dynamic
is a very very good thing but sometimes
it's too much of a good thing so here is
another example pulled straight off of
community I think where we have a global
value of x that somehow depends on a
local value if manipulate and notice the
SEL bracket at the far side stays lit
indicating that something is happening
over and over and over what is happening
well this manipulate this first argument
to manipulate is wrapped and dynamic
this dynamic depends on the value of X
and X changes during this evaluation so
even if it doesn't actually change it's
being reset to the same thing over and
over and over how does one avoid this
category of problems well there are
several ways one is to specify that I
only want particular symbols to be
tracked
you one can do that and manipulate with
the track symbols option here we specify
a single value a single variable that we
want tracked setting track symbols to
true will cause this to track all local
manipulate variables and only the local
manipulate variables that works in this
case because X is not a local manipulate
variable it's a global variable also
something that can be done is to
localize these variables so they are not
global so here we have X being itself a
local variable in a dynamic module or
for that matter in a module this kind of
nesting is perfectly fine another
problem that I mentioned so here we have
an example of something that takes a
while to evaluate and something that's
drop-dead fast to evaluate and we want
to show them both at the same time in
the same manipulate and so we when
dragging this around the contour plot
gets reevaluated that's fine we let go
of it it becomes beautiful good now we
drive this point around there's no
reason for the contour plot to be
updating but we haven't given the
manipulated enough information to know
that and so it updates everything that
you've given it and we can avoid this by
careful use of explicit dynamics in
manipulate so here we have the same
input but with a dynamic wrapped tightly
around the thing that's updated when we
move that 2d slider around and now we
can move when we move the contour plot
around it still needs to be reevaluated
but the point can slide effortlessly
across the top of it and and not trigger
the contour plot to reevaluate and we
can push this dynamic even deeper I'd
encourage people interested in this to
follow this link to YouTube for my talk
back in 2015 about this in which I go
into quite a bit of detail and there's
another link here to that same talk in
which I talk about you know manipulate
it's not going to make fast make slow
things fast if you have a fundamentally
slow evaluation you need to think
carefully about why you want to put it
in to manipulate in the first place and
if you do
you want to be setting some options so
that the users experience is not
portable okay
the last category of problems I want to
talk about is our problems related to
initializing and manipulate one
typically wants to do this because when
you open a manipulate from a file that
someone or that you yourself have
written you want you don't want to have
to do some evaluations in order to make
them manipulate work you want those
evaluations to happen automatically one
way to do that is to have the manipulate
specify those evaluations you do that in
two ways one is with the initialization
option to manipulate in which you can
specify any expression to be evaluated
when that manipulate is first displayed
in a session so here we have
initialization set to some function and
the manipulate that so here we have X is
going from 0 to 1 but notice that the
value in the body of the the white
framed area is going from 1 to 2 because
F now has the definition ok another way
one can do this is with save definitions
and this setting save definitions true
all that does is looks for the
definitions on which this manipulate
depends and then embeds them into a
literal initialization option for you so
the result of this is precisely the same
as the previous and another bonus slide
take a look at this this slide answers
the question why doesn't my
initialization get run first and those
of you who are listening carefully I
answered that already Jermel I was
talking during the first during the
previous slide but there's some more
pros here for you to tease that apart so
save definitions
what does save definitions do well it
uses full definition which is a function
that's been in the kernel since version
2 may be version 1 I don't know 1.2 and
it knows how to recurse through
definitions and and find out what is
defined in terms of what it's also used
by other built-in functions like
save and here's just a quick example
that Michael trot wrote some decades ago
we have a utility invert another utility
that depends on invert and a manipulate
that depends on both of them with save
definitions true it grabs the full
definition of inversion I didn't
evaluate that the full definition of
inversion graphics which as you see has
the two down values that we expect
manipulate makes use of full definition
this is the internal package variable
that does that for people who are really
really interested but this will return
exactly the same two down values and
this is what gets injected into
manipulates initialization option save
definitions is a big hammer and people
online have very strong opinions about
it use it when you should and avoid it
when you should I'll just take one more
minute use it when if you have simple
functions that can be dropped in to
manipulates that they don't refer to any
they don't have their fingers throughout
all of global and if you really want
this thing to to jump to life when you
open it from a file I would recommend
against using save definitions if you're
if you're loading package files package
symbols because you don't want save
definitions pulling pieces of a package
together and injecting them into an
initialization far better in that case
is to create the initialization manually
with the needs of that package and full
definition ignores protected and read
protected symbols so if you're dealing
with those you're probably fairly
advanced but you you shouldn't be using
save definitions in that case okay more
bonus slide more bonus slide that's all
I have
manipulate is very useful and those are
the problems that I've seen people have
in real life and maybe that addressed
some of the things that people here care
about so thanks very much for your
attention
[Applause]